my next guest says his wife's life was
saved by turning her onto her stomach
during coronavirus treatment doctors had
told Adam fresco that his wife Stacy who
had Kovac 19 arterial pneumonia and
heart and kidney problems would not
survive he and his children visited her
in hospital to say goodbye when he asked
doctors if there was anything they could
do to save her they suggested turning
her onto her stomach which is known as
proning it is a highly risky procedure
but in this case it works and Adam
fresco joins me now from central London
hello to you Adam so it was March the
22nd
Mother's Day you and your two daughters
got a call from whips Cross Hospital to
say you need to come in and say your
good-byes just talk us through what
happened well I got a I got a call mid
morning saying how quickly can you get
to the hospital which is never good when
especially when the hospital is on
lockdown I got there saw an incredible
doctor called Dave and who told me that
it was critical my wife was unlikely to
survive because she was so ill and said
it was time to call the kids and and say
goodbye so I called them said we had a
chance to visit mom they came down with
their Mother's Day cards and I told them
the truth
and lots of lots of hugs tears sobbing
and just before we went into it and say
goodbye to Stacy I remember saying to
the doctor is there anything weird or
wacky you can do that has worked
anywhere else at an impossible question
for him to answer and we went in put on
the full PPE gear which is so
claustrophobic I don't know how those
guys do it hour after hour the kids read
out their Mother's Day cards it whilst
they were sobbing which was which was
heartbreaking and and we left I don't
know how long we were in there for and
and when we were back in the waiting
room and up to Dave came back in and
said look there's one more thing we can
try and he described proning but the
caveat was that it was really risky and
because her heart wasn't working
properly we would
more than likely lead to a fatal heart
attack but she was going to die anyway
so the three of us discussed it and we
and we came to the only conclusion that
there was nothing left to lose we had to
try it
and the doctor date said stay because if
anything goes wrong it will go wrong
really quickly he came back after now
and said she was still fighting still
surviving go home will ring you if
anything bad happens and that night the
phone didn't ring
they turns her again the next day for
about 15 hours and the phone didn't ring
Monday nights and then on Tuesday
evening that the house phone did ring
and it could only be that the hospital I
remember running for the phone my heart
pumping I couldn't I couldn't hear what
was being said it was a lovely nurse I
believe called Abbey who started the
conversation with can I just say what a
remarkable woman your wife is and she
was responding well to being turned that
the oxygen was better now that blood
flow was better she was still on life
support but the nurse said for the first
time they were optimistic not out of the
woods yet and then Adam I think was it
another day or two later the phone rang
again you saw hospital ICU come up on
your phone your heart must have been
pounding again and then you go to a
voice at the other end of the phone well
and said would you would you like to
speak to your to your wife which would
knock me back but they issue as though
just bringing her round from
life-support being unconscious and they
wanted to see how aware she was so I
spoke to her told her that we we loved
her she had to keep fighting and the
nurse said when she heard my voice she
opened her eyes and when I said you have
to keep fighting she mumbled okay but
they that staff there were just
brilliant one one nurse gave me her
personal mobile number so I could sends
her a picture of myself and the kids
which you then printed out taped to some
of the equipment around Stacy's bed and
every hour or so someone would go up to
Stacy and say Adam the kids they're
there with you their fight
you have to keep fighting and Stacy said
she remembered some of those messages
though they were just all incredible and
what's remarkable is given the pressures
that these doctors and nurses are under
as you say the amount of time that they
took to communicate with you keep you
informed all the time and to keep Stacy
in that conversation as well actually I
I don't know how they do it to say thank
you to the whole team there that saved
your wife life wife's life is just
inadequate and the main reason that we
we've done these interviews is to give
back to say thank you and also if people
can donate to go to the Just Giving comm
slash arts charity to which we've cross
hospital is part off to donate anything
anything they can because these these
guys are risking their lives day in day
out and if they're going back to their
friends to live with their friends and
family they're risking their lives as
well it says it's truly heroic so a few
days after you'd spoken to Stacy as she
was beginning to wake up she was
transferred out of ICU
yes about a week she was in ICU for just
over a week then went through the high
dependency units for a day or two and
then went to a respiratory ward and then
about 20 days later I got a call from
Stacy saying would you come and pick me
up which was just incredible I don't I
don't think I'd let myself believe that
there could be a happy ending after
going through that horror of being told
your your wife is going to die and then
having to tell your kids to give
yourself that that hope was I didn't
want it to risk being brought down so
quickly even though I know how strong
she is which is proved she's really good
she's exhausted she's very weak she says
she feels like she's been hit by several
trucks and but everyday I can
see that she's getting slightly stronger
yeah we've got time it whether it takes
six weeks or six months we've got time
for her to recuperate which I'm just
it's only grateful for and I imagine you
will be clapping louder than most this
evening come eight o'clock Adam the
first the first day Stacy was home was
last Thursday so at 8 o'clock we went to
the window and we all clouds absolutely
yeah we'll be putting some extra effort
into it Adam thank you very much indeed
for telling your story an incredibly
traumatic story but one with a happy and
positive ending we wish safe see all the
best with her continued recovery
Roger thank you thank you